les soignants sont de nouveau dans la
rue les travailleurs du médico-social
manifestent aujourd'hui il réclame
l'embauché massive de personnel
l'ouverture de licher une hausse des
salaires dans les secteurs de la santé
de l'action sociale on retrouve tout de
suite notre reporter david khalifa
bonjour david plus qu'un cri de colère
c'est un appel à l'aide que lancent les
soignants
[Musique]
effectivement sophie plusieurs centaines
de personnes réunies dans les rues
parisiennes un parti de l'hôpital cochin
pour dénoncer la stratégie du
gouvernement qui consiste à laisser ait
circulé massivement le virus pour
maintenir l'activité économique
plusieurs revendications ans pour ses
soignants et aides soignants qu'on a
l'impression à d'écouter en boucle
depuis deux ans malheureusement pour eux
d'abord une revalorisation salariale
pour le personnel médical et non médical
ceux qui assistent les soignants
également arrêté la fermeture de lits la
réouverture de ces services qui sont
essentiels dans cette cinquième bague
aussi aux virulentes soit elle
l'importance pour ces soignants est cet
après midi est de démontrer justement
que ces problèmes sont existants sont
beaucoup plus sont beaucoup plus
importants et bien présent depuis une
vingtaine d'années au sein de l'hôpital
un public dans le viseur notamment le
cdur de la santé pas suffisant alors je
vais écouter
les professionnels ne voient pas le bout
du tunnel et fait qu'ils n'ont pas de
perspective on a un gouvernement qui ne
s'exprime toujours pas sur la nécessité
en tout cas de recruter du personnel et
former massivement du personnel et les
professionnels attendent toujours des
revalorisations salariales digne de
notre pays puisque tous les pays
européens rémunère mieux en
professionnel il faut vraiment un choc
d'attractivité en tout cas pour
l'hôpital public et pour les
établissements du sanitaire du social et
du médico social sinon nous n'aurons
plus de pain et de professionnels dans
ses prochaines semaines et c'est vrai
que c'est très difficile pour les
professionnels de se projeter alors
qu'il n'ya pas de reconnaissance
tangible de ce gouvernement le système
de santé il est débordé actuellement il
est au bord de l'effondrement et c'est
pas parce que macron s'amuse à emmerder
les non-vaccinés que en fait ça change
quelque chose nous n'avons ni past
supplémentaire ni moyen supplémentaire
ni budget supplémentaire d'aucune sorte
donc on se demande qui en merki moi je
vais vous donner la réponse c'est merci
monsieur macro et son gouvernement et
tous ses playmobil qui vote qui nous
supprime tous les ans tous les jours de
l'argent pour avoir des postes
soignant et du matériel supplémentaire
vous voyez derrière moi à la
mobilisation est au rendez-vous
l'objectif principal est gay était
évidemment d'interpeller le gouvernement
face à ses responsabilités une audience
à d'ailleurs été demandée le cortège
terminera un sa course au métro varenne
non loin du ministère de la santé si
beaucoup david khalifa